donc je vous demanderais d'après dire
très fort vladimir plaie de serre
bonjour bonjour bonjour mon ange
l'admirent plaide serge je travaille à
l'agencé spatiale européenne je suis
responsable de la police
je suis expert en microgravité je vais
vous parler aujourd'hui ah oui voilà de
vaincre la pesanteur en tombant pourquoi
il faut tomber pour vaincre la présente
d'abord je voudrais remercier les
intervenants précédents des
organisateurs également
et puis comme le thème la session et
trouver le nord et bien j'espère que
vous allez comprendre le lien je vous
parlais du haut et du bref il faut
tomber alors je vous propose de faire
une expérience imagine mois qui a été
proposé par albert einstein ya plus d'un
siècle
c'est l'expérience de la lacc h
ascenseur qui descendent les trois cas
de figure dans les trois cas de figure
la cage d'ascenseur décent mais pour des
causes et avec des effets différents la
premier cas de figure
l'ascenseur descend avec un excès ration
petit à petit que la création la
pesanteur qui vaut 9 points 80 mètres
par seconde au carré si vous rappeler
vos cours de physique de base qui n'a
jamais pris l'ascenseur dans sa vie
lever la main personne très bien je peux
passer le k numéro 2 cette fois-ci
l'ascenseur est accélérée vers le bas
imaginer une main géante qui pousse la
cage d'ascenseur et le bail si on a
représenté un moteur de fusée et bien là
qu'est ce qui va se passer
le bonhomme soudainement à va être
propulsé au plafond et se taper la tête
au plafond
est ce que c'est juste que j'aime dire
pas tout à fait on pourrait dire
également non c'est pas ça qui se passe
c'est plutôt la cabine d'ascenseur qui
est accélérée qui le rattrape et qui lui
tape sur la tête
eh bien vous a mis le doigt sur quelque
chose de très important c'est le point
de vue quand vous avez une discussion
avec quelqu'un veut aller votre point de
vue vous le confronter avec votre
interlocuteur
et bien c'est pareil en sciences vous
avez également des points de vue ses
points de vue s'appelle des repères ou
des référentiels sont représentés par
trois flèches ont ici un repère qui est
attachée à la capte ascenseur et un
autre qui est à l'extérieur au sol
eh bien on va dire que celui qui est à
l'extérieur il est fixe il ne bouge pas
il a attaché à la terre solide on va
l'appeler inertielle absolue fixe comme
vous voulez c'est du vocabulaire celui
qui attachés à la cabine en descente
eh bien on va l'appeler relatif en
mouvement non inertielle bon voilà du
vocabulaire encore une fois et bien si
je suis assis là dans le coin et que je
regarde je suis bien là si attachés avec
une ceinture
je me tiens les mains et les pieds est
ce que je vois c'est qu'en fait c'est
mon copain mon collègue qui lui va
monter au plafond par contre si je suis
comme le bonhomme à l'extérieur les
pieds au sol et que je vois le tout
toute la scène et qui a une fenêtre je
vois l'intérieur ce que je vais voir je
vois non c'est pas le bonhomme qui est
monté c'est la cabine qui a été plus
vite qui a été accélérée qui la rattrape
et lui a tapé sur la tête et donc le
point de vue c'est important également
troisième cas de figure la cage
d'ascenseur descend avec une accession
petit à cette fois-ci égale exactement à
l'expiration de la pesanteur 9 80 mètres
par seconde ou capter à ce moment là le
bonhomme à l'intérieur qu'est ce qu'il
va faire il va pas rester les pieds au
sol il va pas monter au plafond il va
rester entre les deux flotter entre ciel
et terre en quelque sorte
il va pouvoir se dire deux shows n'y
tiens je suis en train de flotter
librement
c'est parce que soudainement la gravité
a disparu la gravitation à tout à fait
paru dans l'univers premières
conclusions parfaitement correct il peut
tirer de son observation
deuxième chose qui peut se dire tiens je
suis en train de flotter librement
c'est parce que je suis en train de
tomber avec la même vitesse mais surtout
la même accélération que le véhicule
dans lequel je suis deuxième observation
deuxième conclusion parfaitement correct
également et c'est à partir de cet
indice sert nabili t4 de rennes chaîne a
pu continuer ensuite par après poser le
postulat de la relativité générale on la
patinoire va s'arrêter à définition de
l'impesanteur est en fait ce qui se
passe ici il va rejeter la première
interprétation il sait que c'est
impossible d'annuler la gravité dans
l'univers il faudrait que toutes les
masses soient mises égal à zéro où se
trouvait un distance infinie ce qui
n'est pas possible physiquement et donc
il va rater la première observation
accepté la 2ème effectivement et de se
dire je suis en train de tomber avec la
vitesse est un extrait ration que le
véhicule dans lequel je suis en prêt une
fois c'est une question de point de vue
si je suis assis là dans le côté dans le
coin l'aps et que je me tiens bien je
vais voir effectivement mon collègue qui
va flotter librement sans poids je
verrai son imposante si je suis à
l'extérieur les pieds bien au sol et que
je vois le tout toute la scène à travers
une fenêtre je verrai non pas la
pesanteur de mon collègue mais je verrai
la chute libre
je verrai le to qui tombe brutalement
tout à fait librement sans aucune
entrave
alors qu'est ce qui se passe à ce moment
là
ce parce que tout ce qui est à bord d'un
va simplement flotter librement comme
non seulement mon collègue mais
également l'objet qu'il tenait en main à
côté ce que vous avez compris maintenant
la différence entre les deux oui non
mais ça m'étonnerait parce qu'en fait ça
prend des années pour bien comprendre ce
qu'est l'imposante voici un objet que
j'utilise pour permet démonstration
c'est une petite boulette de papier elle
pèse 100 g donc masse constante n'y a
pas de réaction de thermonucléaire de
désintégration thermonucléaire à
l'intérieur et donc la masse est
constante le poids par contre être
variable le poids est de 100 g force ou
à newton à peu près qu'est ce qui se
passe si j'écarte les doigts on va
essayer 3 2 1
expérience réussie bravo alors qu'est-ce
qui ça ce moment là la masse est en
constant le poids d'un newton temps que
je le tiens entre les doigts dès que
j'écarte les doigts l'objet est
directement en état de chute libre et
donc son poids est nulle 0 newton
jusqu'au moment où il touche le sol et
une force de réaction qui apparaît et le
poids devient de vaud à newton
maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe si je
donne à cet objet une accélération dans
nulle diriger vers le autrement dit je
le jette en l'air et je le rattrappe
question à partir de quel moment est ce
qu'il est en étapes de chute libre et
donc d'un pesanteur quelqu'un bon alors
je vais vous rassurer
c'est pas juste le point oui aux avants
de qu'ils affinent montée avant des sens
et non plus pas la partie descendante
seulement c'est tout le mouvement donc
en partie le mont houy quitte ma main la
partie ascendante et puis à partie
descendante pourquoi parce que le sait
la seule force qui agit au moment où je
me lance c'est l'attraction
gravitationnelle peut négliger le
frottement de l'air vu que les vitesses
sont très faibles et donc en fait à tout
moment cet objet est en état de chute
libre pendant la phase montante
ascendante et la phase descendante
troisième expérience je donne maintenant
une vitesse initiale avec un certain
angle incliné sur l'horizontale
autrement dit j'ai dans l'assemblée
comme ceci merci bravo à vous a vu cet
objet décrit une courbe qu'on appelle
une parabole c'est un mouvement
balistique non propulsé parce qu'il ya
aucune force qui agit sur cet objet sauf
la gratuité
et sur ce numéro 4 j'ai besoin de deux
volontaires un garçon et une fille s'il
vous plaît personne je vais en des idées
j'ai pas beaucoup de temps alors s'il
vous plaît aidez moi je n'en tenez là
mademoiselle voilà un type très bien on
a trois chaises
voilà cette expérience très court mais
très dangereuse
cela ne vous enfuyez pas rester là oui
oui on a ce mais dans le même temps deux
bouts de buddh où se joue même pas dans
le même état que connaissent les
astronautes à bord de la station soit 6
internationale on va se mettre en état
d'apesanteur
ça va dans trop belle pas de problème
mené là à côté de moi monté sur les
chaises on se donne la main on compte
jusqu'à 3 1 2 3 et on saute et voilà
brafman audible up lorsque pendant une
fraction de seconde
pendant une fraction de seconde notre
poids était zéro alors je vais pas vous
demander qu'on vient poser mademoiselle
ce serait fort indiscret de ma part je
pèse moi-même 81 kg et a pendant une
fraction de seconde le temps que les
pieds ont quitté la chaise jusqu'au
mandaté au sol mon poids était de 0 kg
merci pouvez retourner à votre place
bien voilà résumons-nous la pâte
apparaît dans un véhicule en chute libre
la chute libre apparaît dans un véhicule
qui n'est soumis qu'à la seule force de
gravité la somme de toutes les autres
forces doit être égale à zéro alors si
important de dire ce qu'elle imposante
heures c'est important également de dire
ce qu'elle n'est pas la pesanteur
n'apparaît pas dans une enceinte où on
ferait du vide c'est pas apprécié entre
6 et pas le poids de l'air qui pèse un
obscur un objet sur une surface ce n'est
pas du non plus à une vitesse importante
comme ici l'avion et ce n'est pas du non
plus l flottaison neutre comme les
astronautes
quand il s'entraîne sous l'eau ce n'est
pas non plus dû à une distance très
élevé d'une planète ce que ici à la
surface de la terre nous sommes
directement en état d'apesanteur
également alors voici les plates formes
qu'on utilise mais la première c'est la
torah chute libre
pardon la tour a su revenir en arrière
voilà merci la torah suc libre
prennent ici qui nous donne cinq
secondes en chute libre l'avion en vol
parabolique je vais vous décrire tout de
suite nous avons également des fusées
sont qui monte jusqu'à 700 km d'altitude
qui nous donne entre 5 et 13 minutes
d'impesanteur on utilise également des
satellites automatique
on utilise également la station spatiale
internationale dira tout autour de la
terre à 400 km à peu près l'altitude
voici l'avion qu'on utilise c'est un
airbus
oui il est là voilà un airbus a310 qui
vous voyez ici d'en face un petit peu
acrobatique puisque c'est une phase
qu'on appelle le pool up où l'avion est
accélérée vers le haut avec un angle de
monter jusqu'à 50 degrés alors je vous
rappelle qu'un avion au décollage
d'école avec un angle de monter de vie
degré 10° 12 degrés maximum 15 degrés
ici on est à plus de deux fois et demie
le maximum autorisé
pourquoi ça et bien le pilote à partir
d'un vol horizontal pardon à 6000 mètres
je reviens en arrière à partir de 6000 m
le pilote va accélérer en mettant les
moteurs à fond en même tiré sur les
commandes cabré l'avion arriver à un
angle de monter de 50 degrés le pilote
coupe les moteurs
il n'y a plus aucune force qui agit sur
l'avion sauf la gravité l'attraction
gravitationnelle qui est toujours là on
peut pas annuler la gravité l'avion de
par sa vitesse initiale va continuer à
monter
déjà en face d'un pesanteur en phase de
chute libre rappelez-vous expérience
numéro 3 mais c'est exactement ça arrivé
au sommet de la courbe il va continuer à
descendre cette fois ci en chute libre
et quand l'angle de piquer arrive à 40
degrés il est grand temps pour le pilote
de remettre les moteurs à fond de tirer
sur les commandes
et puis de revenir un vol horizontal
donc trois phases dans cette manoeuvre
la phase d'accélération initial qu'on
appelle le pilote la phase
d'accélération final on appelle le pool
out et c'est le prix à payer on pèse en
fait deux fois pratiquement deux fois le
poids de son corps pour avoir la face
d'un pesanteur de microgravité au milieu
qui dure une vingtaine de secondes
on répète ça comme ça une trentaine de
fois par vol et donc un vol nous donne
30 x 20 secondes qui nous fait dix
minutes
trois vols lors d'une campagne qui fait
30 minutes et si on fait trois campagnes
dans l'année on aura ainsi recréé 90
minutes d'impesanteur l'équivalent d'une
orbite de la station spatiale
internationale la petite vidéo ici va
vous montrer sa non un peu plus de
détails cela nous a demandé ce week end
wild side 12 ans l'équipe et 9 3 to
quand barack adama les fanatismes
nous sommes au fond ce sera de gravity a
demandé aux deux parties de lui le
maximum étrangers à 11h00
nous savons par hank to come back and
you site pour de poulet rôti de porc
bien le faire photo jim nous parle
d'accélérer tout come back et 26 pour
gallinari tout comme marc venturi wan
jifei légal du ring 10 polarization khan
reach a tout apporté tout outil 1
on en distingue d'abord je respecte tout
dit après deux voies et rohner et oui à
bac 2 3 en laye crédit photo jba rythme
des crises il n'a pas terminé
samedi 6 6 3
twitch maximum aux bras et au dos et
dridi sortie probable ah oui elle a
toutes les minutes of might maritime et
profonde quintiles le 10 déc aps la diva
d'un team energy and is weak a failli
réaliser couvrant tout bois en orbite
avant 10 heures et que votre avis la
praille bombay alors alors je vois
surtout de suite le petit poisson on l'a
ramené bien vivant il a encore vécu de
nombreuses années il est mort de mort
tout à fait naturel de vieillesse
voilà vous avez également un opérateur
qui est la tête en bas je mets en bas
entre guillemets parce qu'en fait il n'y
a ni eau ni bas en impesanteur on peut
très bien aller marcher au plafond
parce qu'en fait ce qui nous contraint
ici sur le sol c'est bien la pesanteur
qui nous tire vers le bas et donc en
apesanteur et bien cette notion
disparaît tout à fait alors on peut
ainsi recréer des périodes de vingt ans
des pesanteurs qui sont très pratiques
pour faire un tas d'expériences pour
préparer également expérience spatiale
pour entraîner des astronautes avant d
envoyer dans l'espace
et puis en fait l'étape suivante c'est
les envoyer à bord de la station
spatiale internationale qui étend une
énorme structure qui fait 100 mètres de
long 80 m de large avec des modules
également venant de plusieurs pays en
fait 14 pays se sont associés la russie
les états unis le canada le japon et dix
pays européens dont la france partie
également
et cette station est et comment ça
commençait à être construit en 1980 18
voilà je suis bien et
petit à petit elles étaient assemblées
ainsi en orbite alors depuis l'an 2000
depuis exactement quinze ans maintenant
depuis novembre 2000
tous les terriens n'habite plus porter
un sac je crois que c'est capital a
réalisé je vais le répéter encore une
fois tous les terriens n'habite plus sur
terre depuis 15 ans c'est à dire depuis
novembre 2000
et bien il y a toujours d'abord depuis
trois ans maintenant six astronautes et
cosmonautes hommes et femmes des êtres
humains qui sont en orbite nous sommes
devenus nous la race humaine nous sommes
devenus une race spatiale nous voyageons
dans l'espace depuis 15 ans de manière
continue même si c'est pas très loin
seulement 1 400 km d'altitude
mais au moins nous avons fait le premier
pas nous sommes devenus une race
spatiale depuis quelques temps et
commença et bien en ayant vaincu la
pesanteur entendant de manière continue
cette fois ci à bord de la station
avec une vitesse horizontale suffisant
pour en tombant et bien constamment raté
la terre est allé plus loin et donc
continuer à tourner autour de la terre
et donc pour vaincre la pesanteur
il faut tomber merci pour votre
attention